the third stop on the 2016 grandchester  will take us to the chest capital of the  United States in st. Louis Missouri for  the fourth edition of the sink filled  cup slated to take place from August  fourth through the 16th this classical  tournament will bring the best in ches  to the Midwest Grand Master Levon  Aronian will be back to defend his crown  against the top players in the world  including new st. Louis resident and US  Champion fabiano caruana  two other top US players Hikaru Nakamura  and Wesley so we'll join former world  champion vishy anand to the capital of  chess in the united states  the sink filled cup will be the pivotal  tournament of the grand chest or and  will have a major impact on who the  contenders will be on their quest to  capture the 2016 grand chest Tour  Championship watch all the action live  online at grand chest toward org